[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes en
direct avec sébastien meurant sénateurs
les républicains du val d'oise bonsoir
sébastien meurant merci d'être avec nous
à vos côtés david guiraud porte-parole
jeunesse de la france un somistes
bonsoir à vous également david guiraud
merci d'être là gérald darmanin qui est
donc auditionné ce soir ça continue qui
a tenté clairement de montrer un soutien
sans faille à la police vous l'avez
entendu j'imagine en tout cas pour la
première partie sébastien meurant
il était important pour vous qu'il
s'explique le ministère le ministre de
l'intérieur ce soit il est important car
on assiste à des qit la déliquescence du
pouvoir il ya une crise de l'autorité et
qui n'a pas démarré
lle récemment depuis le début et même
macron nous a inquiétés par cette dérive
autoritaire rappelez vous son surnom
donné par ses troupes s'étaient jupiter
l'épisode benalla a montré tout
l'intérêt d'avoir à filmer certaines
interventions et donc que le ministre de
l'intérieur s'explique c'est bien la
moindre des choses qui s'explique
d'abord devant l'assemblée nationale où
ce vote les lois et je note que cette
loi est cet article et qui pose problème
et puisque cet article à revenir au
sénat c'est de cet article a été voté
par la majorité présidentielle
il est quand même surprenant de vouloir
écrire cet article que m'avait demandé à
priori à la demande du président de la
république non par un comité théodule et
qui a ému même le président de
l'assemblée nationale monsieur ferrand
et y compris la présidente de la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
alors david guiraud on entend sébastien
meuros et d'atr les républicains je
précise qu'ils voilà qui est souligne ce
côté très adroite des ministres de
l'intérieur vous je ne vous demande pas
si gérald darmanin vous a convaincu
devant les députés
simple mais mais ce qui en fait moi ce
que j'observe c'est qu'ils sont en train
de changer de les discours et pourquoi
ils sont en train de changer de discours
pas parce que monsieur darmanin n'est
plus quelqu'un de droite et parce qu'il
ya une mobilisation citoyenne
c'est à dire que des gens sont descendus
à plusieurs centaines de milliers dans
la rue pour dire que les libertés ce
n'était pas quelque chose d'accessoires
et que l'on ne pouvait pas accepter ce
discours qui est toujours le même depuis
des années de dire il faut que vous
sacrifiez d'une partie de vos libertés
soit disant pour garantir votre sécurité
est ce que fait le gouvernement avec la
loi de sécurité globale ce qu'il fait
notamment avec l'article 24 n'est pas
que c'est que en fait ils empêchent aux
citoyens de se protéger d'autres choses
parce que vous savez dans la sécurité et
la sûreté il ya d'autres choses que
juste se protéger de ces autres
concitoyens potentiellement dangereux
mais aussi des abus du pouvoir et des
abus des représentants du pouvoir est en
fait la multiplication des images ne
fait que confirmer que oui il ya des
abus depuis des années et que c'est pas
juste une question de brebis galeuses
dans la police mais deux responsables
police politique de responsables publics
qui n'ont pas voulu organiser des choses
de manière à ce que ça se passe bien et
donc forcément quand vous avez des
discours un peu guerrier comme ceux
darmana au début qui nous disait tout
assumé il ya un temps souvenez vous en
quand même fut un temps où on nous
disait qu' il n'y avait pas de violences
policières qu'il n'y avait aucun racisme
que tout allait bien et c est bien
maintenant la réalité se confronte à
monsieur darmanin il change de discours
donc effectivement il a un peu sur la
sellette
pourquoi parce que moi j'estime quand
même que quand vous changez de disque
que vous changez de politique c'est
difficile d'incarner de ligne politique
à la fois oui alors justement je me
demandais si le son on l'avait justement
ce sont de gérald darmanin qui évoque
ces violences policières et qui n'est
pas tout à fait d'accord justement avec
l'opinion publique sur ce thème on va
écouter le ministre de l'intérieur qui
s'exprimait
c'était cet été j'ai justement lors
d'une audition devant la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale
quand j'entends le mot violences
policières moi personnellement je
m'étouffe la police exerce une violence
certes mais une violence légitime c'est
vieux comme max weber
sébastien meurant c'est ça le problème
c'est ce climat là faute au climat ou
discours guerrier instaurée par le
ministre de l'intérieur est encore
quelques mois selon vous n'allez non le
problème ce ne sont pas les violences
policières il ya des actes qui sont
répréhensibles au sein de la police mais
la violence
elle n'est pas policière la violence et
la lan monte en france il n'y a pas de
sentiment d'insécurité il ya une
véritable violence qui est vécu par nos
concitoyens
et moi qui suis sénateur du val-d'oise
je peux vous dire qu'il ya des années ma
grand mère ne savait pas sa porte
lorsqu'elle était chez elle et que
maintenant ils cédé impossible il ya une
vraie violence qui monte dans la société
il ya tout un tas de phénomènes et les
policiers sont les premières victimes
des violences parce que il y a des
centaines de policiers agressés chaque
jour et le respect des forces de l'ordre
n'est plus ce qu'il a été
donc monsieur madame anna le problème
c'est que il assume un discours qui est
le sien un discours que lui demande
d'assumer le président de la république
puisque il faut plaire à la fois et à la
droite et la gauche
le problème ce sont les actions et ce
sont les résultats d'une politique
on a mis avec le pays à feu et à sang
avec des postures très martial est dans
une période de confinement il est quand
même complètement impensable d'avoir des
centaines de milliers de personnes qui
manifestent et la donne on parle pas les
mesures barrières
donc le problème il c'est un problème
qui est fondamental c'est que ce pouvoir
est en déliquescence et qui a une crise
de l'autorité et qui est alimenté par un
pouvoir qui est impuissant à résoudre
les vrais problèmes de sécurité des
français
car entre la la sécurité mise
l'intérieur et le garde des sceaux il y
a un vrai problème nous a pas échappé
quand même qu'il y a eu la peau de temps
des policiers qui ont été malmenés dans
mon département à herblay qui sont qui
était entre la vie et la mort il ya eu
des cas peu très peu de temps des
attentats terroristes et qu'on a un vrai
problème de sécurité en france et les
violences et un problème de violence
policière c'est le problème
effectivement de dérapage de certaines
personnes mais je peux vous assurer là
je soutiens l'euro
je soutiens
que la police dans son immense majorité
est remarquable et elle est républicaine
donc il ya un an toutes corporations des
acquis sont rentrés en cible là ces
personnes ces policiers il faut être
sanctionné mais dans l'immense majorité
ce qui est scandaleux c'est qu'on peut
voir des black bloc tapez massacrer des
policiers on peut voir des policiers qui
attendent des jugements d un policier
assez gras et donnant quatre ans vous
rendez compte ça fait quatre ans qu'il
attend un jugement
donc là il ya un problème de cohérence
de ce pouvoir qui à la fois sécuritaire
et justice prenez une réelle montre une
david guiraud sur ce problème de crise
d'autorité en france il n'ya plus de
sécurité votre réaction
non mais on nous dit que il s'agirait de
certains policiers personne n'est dit
que tous les policiers sont des racistes
salle aux violences et passe à la
question la question c'est quand vous
regardez par exemple les images de
michel est clair vous avez quatre
policiers qui sont des agresseurs sont
nés puis degardin à pied ce sont des
agresseurs n'y a pas d'autre mot bon
mais le problème là dedans c'est qu'ils
sont pas que quatre il y en a 15 autour
d'eux pendant les deuxième set celles
qui ont été données par l'outsider qui
sont passifs face à des choses compte
qu'il ne devrait pas accepter par
exemple michel déclare se prend des
coups au visage alors qu'il ne se défend
pas par terre il ya aucun des collègues
de ces gens violents qu'il peut qu'ils
ne pensent à les arrêter de la même
manière que vous avez de plus en plus ce
genre d'événement ou en fait sur par
exemple ce fiasco bien il ya des
mensonges donc on ne sait pas évaluer
les choses et surtout les gens violents
dans la police aujourd'hui sont ce qui
entraîne des policiers qui sont sûrement
intègre au jour le jour je dis pas le
contraire mais ces gens violon intel
entraînent dans leur logique
les policiers qui eux ne gagnerait à
être détachés débarrasser de ce genre de
policiers aux violences et à dire qu'en
fait les pouvoirs publics ont organisé
une situation où les mauvais éléments de
la police ont une influence considérable
dans les actions parfois dans les
paroles sur des policiers qui moi je
veux bien le reconnaître qu'ils font
bien leur boulot parfois mais qui se
retrouvent dans ces logiques là et
logiques parfois de un peu de silence
parfois d'omerta et souvent quand vous
regardez les récentes affaires les
policiers mentent
voilà c'est quelque chose qu'il faut
alors ils demandent pas tous mais sur
sophia chouïa sur sur cédric joue via
par exemple les policiers ont menti ce
sont les vidéos qui ont permis à la
fille de
vous voyez c'est aussi ça c'est des
histoires humaines de la fille d'un père
qui est mort de savoir pourquoi et
comment son père était mort et le faux
usage de faux est une pratique
malheureusement aujourd'hui dans la
police qui s'est trop généralisée parce
qu'on n'a pas voulu contrôler ça on
attaque on a considéré que parce que les
policiers été assermenté ça se passerait
mieux et vous savez moi ça ne me plaît
pas cette situation j'aimerais bien
qu'on n'ait pas besoin de filmer les
policiers mais aujourd'hui pour de
beaucoup de citoyens
c'est la seule arme qu'ils ont face à
des policiers assermentés et c'est ça le
problème de la loi sécurité globale
c'est que aujourd'hui malheureusement
c'est leur seul instrument de défense a
beaucoup de citoyens face à des
policiers qui effectivement parfois en
viennent à mentir et ses salles parce
que effectivement vous avez un journée
un policier qui fait une journée de
travail où il va sauver des gens où il
va aider par exemple des fameux qui se
font battre par leur conjoint je ne le
nie pas mais il suffit qu'une fois dans
la journée la justice sur cassure un
citoyen pour que le rapport de ce
citoyen là par exemple sur un contrôle
au faciès qui dérape pour que le rapport
à la police de ce citoyen là soit
durablement impacté est de plus en plus
et effectivement pendant les
manifestations des gilet jaune on a vu
ce sentiment quelque part pas se
généraliser ya encore beaucoup de gens
qui ont confiance à la police mais quand
même le gouffre s'accroît ces hangars
donnez moi la généralisation à partir du
1er juillet des caméras piétons annoncé
un par gérald darmanin lors de son
audition ça peut être un début de
solution
dans le contexte actuel c'est ça amène
un peu d'accalmie
mais il l'a dit le problème ce ne sais
pas si c'est pas assez par les caméras
le problème c'est que le métier de
policier le métier de ses rêves mettez
les forces d'ordre est de plus en plus
difficile et c'est pas de la faute des
forces de l'ordre
la société est de plus en plus violente
il ya des causes et ses cecos il faut
traiter parce que vous allez boire et
nous fournir les policiers nationaux les
policiers municipaux
bientôt on va devoir fournir aussi les
caméras au vigile dans les magasins qui
sont pillés par des casseurs
ces agressions répétées fonds qui lie à
un climat et une réelle insécurité qui
monte
année après année en france et cette
insécurité se répand auparavant c'était
limité dans certaines banlieues on
appelait chaude et aujourd'hui c'est
partout en france où il y à un
affaiblissement énorme de la ceinture de
la sécurité en asie
vivement de l'autorité et l'autorité des
policiers qui étaient inhérents au port
d'un uniforme au respect que l'on devait
à l'art à la loi aux règles aux usages
et aux moeurs
c'était 7,7 ce respect de l'autorité et
de moins en moins partagez donc les
caméras sont un début de solution mais
le problème est tout autre
le problème c'est de faire en sorte que
les policiers ne soient pas adressé que
les policiers soient dans un climat de
sérénité et la mettez vous à la place
des policiers
il ya bien plus de policiers de blessés
que de dérapages et de bavure et hélas
gevrey raciste et ça fait les gros
titres
tous les médias en parlent là on a
complètement oublié les policiers qui
ont été victimes d'agressions les
policiers assassinés les policiers ont
ça fait pas les gros titres
donc il ya il ya il ya un vrai problème
de climat en france qui est un climat
certains disent de climat de pseudo
guerre civile lorsque lorsqu'on a des
manifestants qui se permettent devant
l'oeil des caméras de briser des
commerces de saccager l'arc de triomphe
on n'a jamais vécu ça même pendant les
heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire
l'arc du triomphe des symboles de la
nation de la république n'ont pas été
saccagés et là le canton dont on parle
il ya quelques centaines de black de
l'audition peau du luc le pouvoir nana
n'intervient pas là il reste condamné à
la source le racing nous évite
déroulement de la fin c'est déjà la fin
pour revenir à la question initiale de
notre débat ce que ça changerait quelque
chose finalement le départ du ministre
de l'intérieur qui a d'ailleurs je le
rappelle renouvelé sa confiance au
préfet de police parisiens l'allemand
moi je pense que c'est par exemple le
départ du préfet l'allemand changerait
concrètement des choses parce que je
pense que c'est un homme dangereux pour
monsieur darmanin moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est surtout de changer sa politique
non j'ai appelé plusieurs fois à la
démission de nombreux membres du
gouvernement donc je peux le refaire
mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui ce qui est
important c'est de garantir les libertés
publiques et de retirer la loi sécurité
globale quant au climat de violence
qu'on énonce attendait ça n'est pas vrai
qu'on n'a jamais connu cette situation
pendant les filets jaunes sur le saccage
de leur doctrine vous rappelez vous les
image de mai 68 sont infiniment plus
violente ces des voitures retournées sur
tout ce tout une avenue sur tout un
boulevard saint germain et cetera et
pourtant il n'y a pas eu autant de
m'arracher il n'y a pas eu de dieu et
bornier donc en fait il faut regarder
les choses avec lucidité
aujourd'hui il ya un gouffre qui se
créent et la question si on veut arrêter
de voir à la fois des citoyens se faire
frapper et en même temps aussi
et parce que c'est important je le
reconnais arrêtez de voir cesser ces
situations aussi de violence envers les
fonctionnaires de police
il faut qu'on s'organise refondre
totalement par exemple le fonctionnement
de la police nationale rck et stationner
le rôle de l'igpn est évidemment il ya
aussi des choses à faire et urgemment
par exemple vu les images notamment de
mediapart et c'est quelque chose que
personnellement je dis depuis longtemps
il faut dissoudre les bacs qui sont
devenus un instit une institution très
honnêtement qui sont dangereuses pour de
nombreux citoyens et dont je ne vois pas
très bien l'utilité aujourd'hui
concrètement pour les gens sur le
terrain
merci à vous deux en tout cas sa frappe
face à l'objet d'un autre débat cv ça me
rend et david guiraud
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france